hallo hallo christopher ich bin links
von statur und zwar ich habe vor ein
paar monaten aber es hat eine parodie
über deine fresse video gemacht also von
glänzen das lässt sich die jungen
einblicken ja das ist eigentlich ganz
gut bei den zuschauern angekommen und
dann wurde ich halte ich mal fragen wie
dieses video hat findest du den text
findet die video wieder den rückstand
ist wieder das mit einfach allgemein
findest findet es lustig - muss nicht
lustig fühlst du dich dadurch
angegriffen oder lacht er darüber dass
wir durch halt mal interessieren
und ja ich habe natürlich auch von dann
halt die fresse gold ein video gemacht
und 20 euro die das letzte mal hier
unten ein becken maximal anderen lust
hast und ich würde mich freuen wenn das
auch noch kommentieren würdest und sonst
was ist das eigentlich von meiner seite
ist einfach andere von mir und
zeigt alle die natur die affen für
parodien ist ein cooler typ auf jeden
fall
was soll ich euch sage was zu sagen will
ich fand das ein 20 jahren sowie zwei
tage schneider nicht gehört ist erstmals
auch ganz okay das ist jetzt so zum
totlachen oder so aber es waren worte
warum nur auf eine art und weise gemacht
wo ich das noch zu verstehen und
akzeptiere so muss das auch noch cool
finden kann so aber
so andere leute
kommen später auf jeden fall ging es
erstmal um den bruder hier in school
alter wenn es erfolg macht du mit deiner
kreatur firma voran kommt dann mach
weiter dick macht noch 300 parodien von
mir werden noch zehn alben kommen auf
jeden fall kann es von mir aus trier
wieder eine prima aber halt alles mit
den rahmen ja
so ich danke meinem freund danke für die
aufmerksamkeit und